I want to start this week off by abiding
by one of the rules I set up when we
launched this operation I said that if
you guys fact-check me I would address
it on the show I did actually make a
minor error last week believe it or not
while talking to my guests majnu oz I
mistakenly said that Ben Carson was a
neuroscientist when in fact he's a
neurosurgeon that was really just a slip
of the tongue but a couple of you called
me out on it so I wanted to correct
myself
of course at the end of the day whether
he's a neuroscientist or a neurosurgeon
one thing I hope he will not become his
President of the United States we got a
really great response to our interview
with Majid last week actually when we
finished I felt like again we had been
part of an important conversation that
needs to be had more this of course is
the irony of the regressives that bash
people like MA jet and Sam Harris here
you have two people from very different
walks of life trying to promote secular
values and coexistence whether you agree
with them or not on every point is
totally irrelevant it should be obvious
to anyone with half a brain that these
are the guys trying to find a peaceful
way forward don't take my word for it
though listen to them speak themselves
and by the way you can disagree with
them on where they stand on certain
issues yet acknowledge that they're
having a very difficult dialogue on
extremely heated topics that most people
are completely afraid to have in the
first place
when a journalist calls Maju to porch
monkey and sam a racist it exposes who
the real extremists are in case you
missed it on Friday night's real time
Bill Maher had an excellent sit-down
with Richard Dawkins on this new split
on the left I was thrilled to hear Bill
Maher actually used the phrase
regressive leftist bill credited Sam
Harris for coining the phrase though
from what I understand Majid was using
it as far back as 2012 in any event the
fact that it trickled up to Bill shows
you that the discussions we're having
here on the show as well as the ones
that you guys are having on Twitter and
YouTube are actually making a difference
that's the beauty of the internet you
can get issues to actually bubble up
until mainstream takes notice there's
evidence of the awakening that I've been
talking about all over the place right
now on Twitter someone asked me if by
calling these people the regressive left
if I'm just resorting to the same type
of name-calling that we accused them of
my answer to this is a hundred percent
no we're giving a name to a problem
we've all seen growing for a long time
now we can debate with them on facts if
they accept facts as such and not just
cherry pick them when suitable for their
narrative the reason I feel like naming
them is so important is because I now
view these regressives as the left's
version of the Tea Party the Tea Party
went unchecked by the right until it was
too late and now the Republican Party is
a fractured mess often only held
together by its worst beliefs
I really believe these regressive czar
doing this to the left and if we don't
have the courage to stop them then a
year or two from now we'll wonder why
our system has even screwed up more than
it is now that's why talking about all
this stuff is important and that's why
we're gonna continue to do so with that
out of the way it's time to sit down
with the outspoken Breitbart
conservative Milo a innopolis and fear
not I won't let any of his syphilitic
screw with my thinking